as the presidential race winds down
president trump and former vice
president joe biden are making their
final push for your vote
this morning president trump was back at
the white house after holding
five rallies and four battleground
states yesterday this morning he
promised
that the crowds that you've seen at his
rallies are going to show up to the
polls
on election day like a red wave i think
the polls are you know suppression polls
and
i think we'll have victory but only when
there's victory i mean
you know there's no reason to play games
and i think we'll have victory i think
you know i look at it as being a very
um you know a very solid chance at
winning
earlier today former vice president joe
biden visited his childhood home in
scranton pennsylvania
pennsylvania is seen as a very crucial
battleground state
it's unclear if a winner is going to be
declared tonight some states
could take days to count all the ballots
and president trump's team
has threatened legal action to prevent
counting votes past election day
8 news now is your local election
headquarters stay with us for team
coverage of election day across southern
nevada and the nation
we have special coverage on 8 news now
starting at 3 30.